[Music]
look who's here our own cooking
confidence coach Nanny Bobby in studio
thanks to Chapman Automotive the
sponsors of this segment doing some
Wonton Soup oh I'm so excited to share
this with everybody and certainly with
you I picked this affirmation card which
tells the story it says my mistakes are
the most important part of My Success in
the kitchen and I'm going to tell you
I've been making wontons since the Lunar
New Year I can't stop I used them for
Super Bowl I fried them it was so much
fun and so I want to show you how to
make them and the soup so let's start
here would be a good Super Bowl a fried
one yeah they were great so first we're
starting with six cups of chicken stock
we're going to add the bok choy let that
cook for two minutes also Nanny Bobby
tidbit is the re the dried shiitake
mushrooms which you reconstitute and I
thought those were weird dried mushrooms
right you need to reconstitute them you
uh put water and moisture in them so
they sit in water for about an hour and
then their regular mushrooms which is
great so that's what we're going to do
with that so that's going to cook now
for two minutes
while we make the wontons okay so we
start at the end now we're going to the
beginning okay so we're going to take
these little wonton sheets and where do
you buy those uh Asian stores okay
um
well you know Whole Foods did not have
them okay I was shocked but I think
Albertsons probably does okay so we're
going to take egg wash and you make egg
wash how
an egg and a tablespoon of water I just
thought maybe you would know that no I
did not I have no idea and we're going
to start with our meat here we've got
recipe calls for pork but this is beef
because I don't do pork and this is the
cornstarch a little bit of shrimp okay
yeah um salt and pepper just put it
right in
Ginger
okay isn't that great I'm going to let
you kind of mix it up and then we're
going to put the Sherry in there which
is just amazing gives it a nice little
kick okay just go ahead really fast fast
fast
now why the cornstarch I don't know all
meats that the Asians use for some
reason they they wipe in cornstarch
because they feel like it makes it more
tender so okay do you feel that way too
um yeah I mean I just like doing it
their way whatever that is right when in
Rome do what the Romans do so same thing
okay so this egg wash on the end we're
going to take this fold it over
right pretty cool yeah there we go fold
it again
put a little egg wash on the edge on the
ends like that and just fold it over and
that's it it makes just this really cute
little flower Bud do you see that it's
so cute so we're going to make another
one and you can start making one too
okay so I'll egg wash it the edges for
you
okay we want to get three in the bowl
and literally we're making an entire
bowl of soup here you can put a little
bit on mine too it's gonna have to come
across you
here we go okay just enough yeah and
fold it over get all the air of it so
put a triangle with your fingers over
and get all the oh you're doing so good
fold it again okay just dip in a little
bit of egg wash with your finger
and there you go what how did you do
that last fold okay so just uh fold
there we go all right and just pinch all
together there you go we've got three of
these they're going to take them we're
going to dump them in the soup
and they're going to cook for three
minutes while we make a couple more okay
and then we're ready to go how much time
do we have left we have less than a
minute yeah but that was in two minutes
the soup cooked totally now three
minutes additional the wontons cook yes
yes and then we're gonna take it out
well they're in there cooking okay so
let's pretend like the shirt for the
three minutes we're gonna throw in the
pea pods we're gonna put in a dash of
the sesame oil here we go I like how
quick this one comes together I mean it
does and I it's non-complicated and it's
so fun I'm addicted to making wontons
addicted to it I love them I fried them
for Super Bowl I just I can't stop
making them and believe me when I first
started they did not look like this they
were a mess so can you make wontons
outside of putting them in soup well
yeah I fried them I tried them for Super
Bowl yeah and you could I made a crab
rangoon in one of them so not with the
meat and here we go a little bit of
delish scallions let me see where the
wontons are here's one
put it in anyway and there we go very
nice I'm gonna try yes I know this one
looks great and of course you know we're
gonna all together spread love like
butter absolutely you can find the
aprons that say spread love like butter
the spatulas and the affirmation cards
at nannybubby.com shop I love it yeah I
know all the shopping okay yeah you
check all of that out by going to Nanny
Bobby's kitchen and Garden on social
media and online at nannybubby.com I
also want to thank Chapman Automotive
for sponsoring this segment always good
to see you we will be right back